zwei gedanken die mir durch den kopf
gehen was passiert wenn meine oma dieses
video sieht gott sei dank hat meine oma
nicht mehr bloß a new day new video it's
time for next wie oft tönt insoweit
glaube ich 2017 sogar daily hochgeladen
er ist das was das für mich für mich ist
es schon aus aber ich hab euch auf
twitter gefragt leute was ihr denn gerne
von mir für texte die ich chris
beantwortet haben wollen würde
wir schauen uns einfach mal hier unter
diesen wunderschönen tweet was ihr mir
da gegeben habe ich bin mir sicher es
sind tolle vorschläge
ich bin mir tausendprozentig sicher ich
vertraue auf ok da schauen wir das erste
kurs von josiah kann ist okay hast du
schöne brüste es nämlich 1
wir machen heute einfach mal eine runde
bullshit christus jahre dümmsten
christine eingeschickt hat machen heute
und wir fangen an mit hast du schöne
brüste und hab ich gesagt bullshit ich
meine wichtige quizzes wichtige fragen
die schon immer mal beantwortet werden
sollten zum beispiel wie gut sind es
case brüste da wurde schon mal wissen ob
du ein schöner bis brüsten brüsten
erkennt das wort buße typ nicht bist
ohne sie vorher zu entblößen
dann schau reinemachen test wissen was
wir bis jetzt schon wisst ihr was ich
werde ich werde im laufe des videos
meine brüste entblößen also bleibt dran
wir sind deine lippen aus dunkel und
bespiegelt schwarz bedecken ein viertel
der brust schön nach hinten
druckschalter die vorstellung schnell
weg damit stehen deine brüste
sie hängen sehr sie stehen wie eine eins
also ich würde sagen die stehen älter
die stehen glaubt mir nicht stehen die
findest du deine brüste selbst ich finde
brüste ekelhaft ganz schön findet sie zu
kleinen finden sie zu groß also leute
ich will euch ja nicht an
ja wirklich nicht deswegen kann ich kann
einfach ich finde brüste ihr glaubt
nicht anklicken es wäre die dreißigste
lüge der menschheitsgeschichte
wie finde ich meinen eigenen aber einige
tricks so ein bh noch nicht nein ich
gehe immer ich gehe mal sind natural
viel
bisher kenne diesen moment wenn ihr
einfach ein natural viel haben wollte
einfach ohne bh umlauf teuren wie auch
immer die aussehen an eurem t shirt
reiben kenne diesen moment ich bin mir
sicher trick sein wahr ich trage keinen
ich zwar wieder in brüssel
ich lasse meine eltern damit spielen
leute ich habe dieses quiz wirklich
überschätzt ich dachte das werfe so ganz
easy wir machen politische fragen
politiker antworten wir lachen alle
zusammen ein bisschen spaß später am
abend aber welcher hat dieses tricks
geschrieben was ist das alter ich lasse
auf jeden fall nicht meine eltern damit
spielen ja immer wenn sie also 15
minuten bahnfahrt kann man auf jeden
fall mit seinem besten spiele aber ich
bin ich auf meinen rücken nicht gehst du
auch frauen ja sind deine brüste hat
heute müssen wir sind da der brüste
operiert never ever habe ich es vor wie
gesagt petrol natural viel natural look
bei mir ist alles natural 160 produkten
oder produkten ja ich will nicht meine
brüste welche körbchengröße hast du b
doppel d tag ein bhkw hamel akademie
schon geklärt finally question okay das
ist aber kein englisch magst du suppe
nein manchmal ja mit stück auch keller
nein du hast schöne brüste
sie haben vier von zehn aufgaben richten
was schöne brüste mit richtig aufgaben
beantworten zu tun
achso moment noch das küste nicht sagt
focke kurzer erstes quiz auf hin was
schreiben dort ihr ja wird es auch gerne
mal wissen wer will das nicht das wäre
geistes video 2017 leute das ist auf
jeden fall geld sowie 2017 okay war
einfach mal dieses christian von léa léa
direkt ans gepostet leer
was hast du für uns letztes gott oh gott
wie gut passe ich zum mikro leute aber
sicher welches christa die sonst
beantworten wie heißt mit games bester
freund der insight supermann dennis in
scope der ist irgendwie ich glaube mirco
rosic heißt eigentlich gab es musik mit
wem hat miguel das video sechs arten von
[ __ ] gedreht allein die tatsache dass
miguel ein video dass sechs arten von
peaches heißt auf seinem youtube kanal
hat sagt schon was aus menschen nicht
gesehen ziemlich abstoßend hat der kasse
leidet supermann dennis korn kräfte
wahrscheinlich oder ja ich sag wieder
wirkung welche augenfarbe hat miguel
gemischt dass der dreck piste scheitern
wie sein lieblingsessen heißt müsstest
du bestimmt wissen ob ich ihn einschätze
schicken uns welche haarfarbe hatte
miguel pablo bevor sie abrasiert hat
heute hätte schon alle möglichen
haarfarben die frage ist welche
haarfarbe der junge in seinem leben
nicht grund für dich mal ausschließen
als graue haare blonde haare
[Musik]
von braun was falsches alle miguel pablo
fans werden in den kommentaren ist kann
ja so was würdest du an einem date mit
mpi unternehmen michael perler
essengehen freizeitpark gar nichts ich
würde ihm einen prank spielen auf jeden
fall break oder stehe nicht auf ihn ich
würde alles machen was er
alter schwede ich bin mir sicher einige
feingold sammlers angekreuzt ich würde
ihm gut auf jeden fall ein break spiel
also wenn ihr mich fragt und
gewissermaßen fragte mich ja wie geil es
halb deutsch halb gehst du gerne feiern
ich gehe wirklich gerne feiern leute
gibt nicht gerne feiern leute bei mir
ist die sache ich bin sehr empfindlich
was die musik angeht also wenn ich in
club reinkommen es schon schickimicki na
dann kann ich auch gleich lassen aber
wenn die richtige musik läuft zum
beispiel dass hier
dann rast ihrer aus leuten ist auch kein
halten mehr der nippel vielleicht muss
ja auch noch kaum also leute seid ihr
rating für die lippen vielleicht passen
zum festlich kürzt 32 wirklicher
präsentiert im schnitt ja ich gehe
manchmal feiern auf jeden fall wand
stehst du frühes aus normalerweise
zwischen 9 und 10 2 gedanken ich mir
gerade durch den kopf gehen was passiert
wenn meine oma dieses video sieht gott
sei dank hat meine oma nicht mehr pablo
stellt euch vor eurer oma wird mir pablo
kennen und sehen dass ihr ein quiz
machen nehme euch fragt wie gut jetzt im
megapark europas das meint ihr wie die
euch enterben würde ok alles da wird dir
gefallen zeigte auf sylt gepasst hat
lois auswertung du hättest eine chance
wenn du dich in paderborn entdecken
würde
okay leute dann wissen wir jetzt auch an
welchem ort ich mich niemals in meinem
leben mehr aufhalten werde wenn es euch
so geht wie mir habt ihr heute in diesem
video alleine mehr gelernt als in 13
jahren schule kein ding ist wirklichkeit
leute ich mache das gerne
wenn ihr dieses mädchen hier unten bei
ein schulungs bilder cute findet dann
lasst doch mal ab und leichter bis zum
nächsten mal haut rein macht's gut und
alter jetzt sitz ich muss auch wissen
sie aufstehen und und